um
you i know that you're a big i know you
so you so you're a huge naz fan
huge eminem guy yep um
you put out a song kind of as an
homage to nas yeah right to both of them
so
to nasa and eminem yeah and uh
you told me recently that nas heard the
song yeah
i haven't really told this to anybody
but uh tell the story man what happened
was this was
2016. so when you put the song out when
i put i put this mixtape out so this was
like a year like things
were just not going well you know what
i'm saying it was right before i did the
whole me monday's thing right
and um just like you know just being a
fan i you know i just wanted to rap over
those beats
so i just did a mixtape called nas and m
it was all their beats you know what i'm
saying
but then one specific song i called a
letter to the king which was like an
actual tribute you know what i'm saying
like the last song on the tape
first verse i'm talking in nas second
verse i'm talking to m and i did it over
the renegade beat
oh fire okay um so and a song came on
fire like a lot of like two dope boys
and girls
pops like everybody posted about it like
yo the [ __ ] is incredible you know what
i
mean
so then we decided to [ __ ] go to
queens bridge and go into detroit and
actually shoot a video for it
and kind of go all out with it you know
what i'm saying and that was that so
that was in 2016 like end of 2016 and
then recently just like
last year so like a good three years
later
i get a facetime out of nowhere and it's
[ __ ] nice
and i'm like yo what the [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying and the reason i didn't
as an m by the way is because like
i mean they were my favorite rappers
like kind of growing up and when i
started doing this you know so i always
say like
if i had to pick my two biggest
influences would be nas in them of
course there's more you know
right right so yeah and it was [ __ ]
nausea you know i'm saying he's like yo
bro i just heard that song
and i'm like which song in that moment
cause it's been like a few years
i didn't realize and i'm all excited
like what the [ __ ] i'm saying like nah's
calling me
and um he's like yo the one you did for
me and m you know what i'm saying
and i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm so happy you
finally heard it he's like nah that [ __ ]
did some to me bro you know what i mean
and he touched his
you know i mean yeah touching his chest
and then we just kind of like chopped it
up about what i got going on i'm working
on a solo project with scott's storage
and this and this and that
um and three days later we was in the
studio you know what i'm saying so even
nas
you went from making a whole project
dedicated partly to knives to getting in
the studio with them
yeah crazy what was that like being in
the studio happiest day in my life you
guys cut a record together
we did uh and the only reason i'm saying
this because i kind of posted on social
media already but
i would want to come back when when we
dropped the regular really talk about it
you know what i'm saying
because i haven't really talked about
this i kind of avoid this question but
yes we have a song and it's [ __ ]
crazy
what was the reason the reason i say
it's the happiest day in my life is not
just because i was in the studio with
nas but
the song came out so perfect you know
as far as like what i would envision
that i would want to do with nas it just
that's the important together you could
have did a song with knives and it could
have been you know
what i'm saying because also i wasn't
ready for it it's not like i expected it
and i had a record ready and i was like
yo get on this you know what i'm saying
it was like three days later
and then you know since i was working
with scott like scott he does
everything on the spot you know what i'm
saying like he doesn't like send you a
bunch of beats right you pick from it
like
you go into the session it starts with a
conversation like what kind of record
you want to do
and then he starts making the beat on
the spot you know what i'm saying that's
the same thing so
i went to the studio with scott um at
scott's house maybe a couple hours
before nas came
like nah said he'll be there like let's
say five o'clock right so i went to
scott's like at two or three
and we [ __ ] created the beat but he
was in like honestly i never seen scott
that excited either you know what i'm
saying like
he's obviously worked with everybody but
he was [ __ ] excited so
he [ __ ] murdered it in like 20
minutes and i started kind of
brainstorming ideas by the time nas came
i felt like comfortable like okay we got
tired
so you recorded this at scott storch's
house yep